you're born today and you inherit all
this stuff that everyone before you all
the domesticated animals other people
domesticated these animals thousands of
years ago all the domesticated plants
all the roads which were built in
England starting with the Romans yeah
calculus which was invented by Newton
500 years ago it's yours for free stuff
how to smelt iron you know all the
knowledge about iron and fishing hunting
fish hooks I talk about fish hooks in
the book like the invention of fish
hooks the wheel you go fire you go on
and on and on all of this stuff which
was just given to you when you were born
was accumulated by other humans across
time and and it's this that makes us so
powerful of species because we have if
you think about it rather pathetic
bodies yeah I mean it's not our bodies
that are making us powerful on this
planet it's our culture our brains that
are making us powerful
I am joined by Yale professor author and
incredibly wise human Nicholas
Christakis professor Christakis welcome
to the show thank you so much for having
me I'm very excited to sit down with you
I really enjoyed you on Joe Rogan about
six weeks ago fell in love with the
content that you guys play and I've been
looking forward to speaking with you
ever since so what are we going to learn
about today well I think the topic that
I've been thinking about lately is human
nature and the part of human nature that
interests me is not so much that part
that we express within ourselves so for
example you know you you could be
spiritual within yourself or you could
be risk-averse within yourself or you
could be you could have wanderlust
within yourself these are qualities that
human beings the world over might or
might not Express and that have been
shaped by our evolution and by natural
selection the parts that I'm interested
in other parts of our human nature that
we express between ourselves for example
do we love each other do we befriend
each other do we cooperate with each
other do we teach each other things
these are things that we also are
naturally inclined to do and those are
parts of our nature that we express
between ourselves and the reason I think
these are important is that for too long
in my view scientists and sort of people
on the street the citizens citizenry
have been overly concerned with what I
would regard to be the dark side of our
nature our propensity to to violence and
tribalism and and lying and you know
selfishness but the bright side I think
has been denied the attention it
deserves because equally we are prone to
all those things I mentioned to love and
kindness and friendship and so forth and
in fact I would argue that those forces
were necessarily more powerful than the
than the evil forces if oh if they
weren't we wouldn't have made it very
far yeah well that well yes but more to
the point we wouldn't be living socially
if every time I came near you you killed
me or or or or gave me false useless
information
yeah or took advantage of me in some way
I would be better off living as a
solitary animal so so that so it must be
the case
the benefits of a connected life
outweigh the costs otherwise we wouldn't
be we wouldn't be living socially and so
that's what I've been interested or
thinking about lately how and why how
and why did they're our evolution not
just shape the structure and function of
our bodies you know how our kidneys work
our pancreas works not or our muscles
work not just shape the structure and
function of our minds you know how we
think how we cope with adversity how we
how we you know how we our personalities
for example but how as well change the
structure and function of our societies
how did we come to live socially the way
we do is it the case that the way we
live the societies we make the world
over actually have been guided by our
long evolutionary past and the answer is
yes
thinking to a lot of the conversations
I've been having recently and a lot of
the books that I lean towards and I know
that a lot of the audience will do as
well I certainly think that there is i'm
discriminating towards the individual on
those books a lot of things to do
understanding our nature recently had
Robert Greene on the laws of human
nature recently had and what qualities
what qualities did he emphasize about
human nature for example oh wow
so he talked about the fact that if you
have brilliance in the world you can be
as talented as you want but without the
ability to understand others and
communicate effectively uh-huh you will
neutralize your brilliance and live a
life filled with pain and misery that
was his okay which and again so we've
touched on two things you've touched on
the fact that it's important to talk
about the social aspect the group not
necessarily always just the individual
you've also touched on the fact that
talking in a positive light is something
which appears to be lacking a little bit
and I would agree I definitely agree on
both counts I think a lot about the fact
that social media posts the anger people
or agree with what they believe are the
two most highly engaged posts on the
Internet presumably
that's going to lead to authors and it
will trickle either up or down however
you call it to academics to also think
what if I want to write a book or have a
paper or a study which is going to be
highly recognized and and interesting at
the moment it would appear that trying
to maybe focus towards the darker side
of human nature the things that are bad
the things that maybe anger people etc
maybe that's a bias I'm not sure whether
you think that's the case well I mean
okay so I mean we have a number of
biases I mean this attention to bad news
is something which many people are
thinking about like why if that's part
of what you're talking about it's why do
we why do we focus on the nasty things
that are around us so much part of the
reason is that it is more advantageous
to you to pay rapid attention to bad
things people theorize than to pay rapid
attention to good things so for example
in our ancestral environment it would
have been more beneficial to you to pay
attention to the location of a fire or a
flood or predators for example than to
which is all bad news then to pay
attention to the location of food for
example which would be good news because
one of them is gonna kill you fast and
the other one you know might take a
while the absence of good news let's say
so so this is one of the reasons that it
is thought that we humans are wired to
preferentially attend to bad news and
you know why why media constantly you
know feature stories of you know misery
and destruction and people click on it
and read it so um anyway so that's part
of I think what what is going on but
there was another part to your question
I I lost track of the other part so part
of it is the anger and the leaning
towards negativity and the other part is
the focus on the individual rather than
the group I think yes the meritocracy
that we're in at the moment with the
garyvee hustle and grind culture that we
have going says that your successes and
failures are yours to hold on your own
and I think that that leads people to
look inward towards how can I make
myself better and not necessarily maybe
think about the group
yes I take your point I mean a lot of
these qualities we have to distinguish
between those aspects of the point you
just made that relate to that are
culturally specific you know that have
to do with the society were raised in or
that are individually specific the kind
of person you are from those qualities
that have been shaped by the long arc of
our our natural selection and and so I
guess what I would say is is that while
it is the case that there's a lot in our
nature that makes us pay attention to
our individuality and how we act in fact
I'm going to come back to this point in
a moment much more interesting to me and
much more relevant to our survival is
our capacity to work together but let me
let me say two things about this first
of all this notion that we're
individuals which you take for which
many people take for granted actually is
kind of an interesting aspect of our
species so it is if you think about it
every every you know we we humans are
capable of being individuals and now we
are we conscious about it but we we
signal our unique identity and we humans
do that with our faces so our faces
every human faces is different while in
principle every pancreas should work the
same every face should not look the same
every face should look different in
those regions of our genome that are
responsible for the faces were born with
those regions are highly variable and
highly reccommend illinit explained in
large measure the great variety of human
faces but not only do we signal our
individual identity not only do each of
us have the capacity to say this is me
not you or not someone else but each of
us is capable of detecting other
people's individuality our brain has
regions that are devoted a lot of energy
and brain space is devoted to the
ability to tell the difference between
people you can look out at a sea of a
thousand people in a nightclub for
example and you can tell each person is
different who is who on the dance floor
and this is important so you go and you
dance with your own partner not some
random person that would be on the far
turn that would be a bad idea and it
would be awkward and and you want to
reciprocate you know like you know this
person
- now it's time to kiss them back not a
different person back so but to do that
but to do that you need to be able to
tell who is who and so this all of this
machinery the face that signals identity
the brain power that detects identity
all of this is an evolutionary luxury
other animals don't do this we do this
and one of the deep paradoxes about
living socially as a mammal is that
first we must be individuals this the
there's a lot of capacity that that that
we have that makes us capable of sick
being individuals in signaling our
identity which actually allows that that
lies at the foundation of our ability to
live socially so so for example this
relates to our ability to be friends how
can you have friends with other people
unless you can track who is who in order
to have a sustained relationship with
Tom and not Dick or Harry you have to be
able to reliably tell this is Tom not
Dick or Harry and this is Tom yesterday
now this is still tom so so this this
this capacity to be individuals is very
deeply connected to our capacity to live
socially so um now I forgot how I went
off on this tangent you asked me about I
wanted to ask that so you've touched on
the fact that other animals don't do
this all right what do you mean don't do
this and how so well have you ever
looked at a sea of penguins and/or cows
I mean I guess farmers can sometimes
tell their cows apart but you know a cow
is a cow I mean there's a herd of cattle
and you don't have any sense is that our
interpretation of the cow or is
presumably the cows must be able to tell
each other apart not as unique
individuals they can tell their
offspring so for example cows can tell
this is my calf I should feed milk to
this calf not anyone else but they don't
tell as far as we know the difference
between strange cows individually here a
hundred strange cows oh but this is this
strange cow and this is that strange cow
elephants do it now we're not the we're
not the only animal that does it to be
clear other social mammals do this so we
do it we have this capacity for
individuality a certain other primates
do it elephants do it
both African and Asian elephants certain
cetaceans do it there's very interesting
evidence from dolphins that dolphins
have names and that they and that they
when they whistle to each other they
have a particular a whistling sound they
make which identifies themselves like a
callsign like you might say you know
Delta 2 1 4 this is tower come in and
and and that means you know that's
identified that's how the Dolphins
repeatedly say I am speaking now this is
me and the other dolphins oh you know
that's you know that's Chris speaking
not Nicholas they can tell the
difference yeah so so and now some birds
can do it too incidentally there's some
evidence that certain very social birds
can Ravens do it Ravens about asses
yeah Ravens are very bad I don't know
about Ravens and individuality I'm sure
it's known I just don't know the answer
Evans a crazy clever man yes very very
fine Ravens and cephalopods they're not
too little yes obsessions yes yes I
think if you come back in in 20 million
years I think Ravens maybe the ascendant
species on the planet and a hundred
million it maybe octopuses don't wait
for the wall between the Ravens and the
octopuses now they'll die out will die
out then the Ravens will be ascendant
then the Ravens are die out the octopus
will be underwater sweet and then they
will evolve there's actually a lot of
debate about whether in other planets
submarine animals could evolve into
sophisticated civilizations because of
the impossibility of having fire under
water yes so some people speculate most
people think this would not be possible
a terrestrial animal to have a
civilization but other people think
that's just us being anthropomorphic
that in some alien planet there could be
very smart underwater creatures that for
example develop the capacity to create
air bubbles into which they put fire oh
they have other other technologies we
can't imagine that they manipulate the
natural world in some way so who knows
but anyway it'll be octopuses 100
million years that's my prediction you
can come back and let me know if if I
just didn't work
as I predicted I have you ever read
children of time by Adrienne Tchaikovsky
no but I do talk about science fiction
utopia's and dystopias in my book
because one of the things that I try to
do is I try to imagine sort of
counterfactual types of social order so
I look at science fiction authors to see
you know what kind of what kind of crazy
social worlds did they come up with and
to what extent did those resemble or not
resemble our own yeah I think if you've
got say if you've got room in the
reading schedule over the coming months
highly recommend children of time by
Adrian Tchaikovsky was I think Pulitzer
Prize Awards or some some crazy big
prize award and in that future
civilization of Earth creates a rapidly
evolving amendment to the genome and
then throws a bunch of monkeys primates
onto a planet which is habitable and
they've all got this particular
amendment and the thinking is we will go
to sleep for a long time and over a
shorter period of time like a couple of
million years they will go from being
normal primates to these highly ascended
beings what happens is all of them this
isn't this doesn't spoil the story
thankfully all of the monkeys burn up on
entry and it turns out that the only
couple of species that are left to
absorb this particular kind of genetic
information a spiders and ants and you
see what happens over a few million
years and Adrian rolls the clock forward
about how they all evolved and one of
the things really interesting that he
touched on was when you have young
planets you don't have the mineralogy
mineralogy you don't have the generals
yeah you know in that mineralogy it's I
can't remember the word you don't have
the right mineral makeup to be able to
create like smithing and stuff like that
it's just not not existed for long
enough to have those fossil fuels etc
etc so they create biological technology
it's absolutely fascinating they make
they make a computer essentially a
computer out of
pheromone controlled ants linked
together in a hive ah yes it's really
really cool but I mean getting out of
the realm of science fiction and back to
thee back to the real world I totally
get what you mean the fact that we are a
social species the fact that we can tell
each other apart it shows that there has
to be a degree of collaboration and also
a lot of what we've been learning about
recently listeners will remember William
von Hippel is episode which is
fascinating talking about pair-bonding
talking about the fact that you have to
spend a lot of time with the partner to
protect the child all of this I guess
lends credence to the fact that we're an
incredibly social species yeah I talk
about pair-bonding and one of things
that's many people take for granted is
that you know we could be a species that
just had sex with each other but we
don't just have sex with each other we
are attached to each other we tend to be
attached to our partners this is very
rare in the mammals it's common in birds
actually which is another interesting
thing again but in mammals you can have
a one-off kind of reproductive
interaction and you don't stay together
in a kind of monogamous way for a
sustained period of time and multiple
you know offspring being produced by the
same Union but we do do that and in
humans that sense of attachment is
expressed or felt as love that we love
our partners and there's interesting
ideas as to why we do that you already
alluded to one of them one has to do
that if you have love between partners
you can have more successful higher
number of surviving offspring so the so
the male will stick around to help
invest in the young but but he will only
do that if he can because this is the
theory if if he can be confident that
those are his offspring not another
man's offspring and one of the ways that
women will signal that to the male the
females will see another female a male
is by by love by expressing love for
them in a way so and anyway so there's
there's some interesting ideas about the
evolution of pair bonding why why we
have this this this phenomenon that is
all around us
that if you stop and think about it is
unnecessary we could be a
actually reproducing species without
having an emotional attachment and yet
we do feel this attachment and the
reason is why it's part of our nature
what purpose does it serve and one of
the purposes is what you eluded to it
it's felt to enhance a reproductive
fitness yeah and so why you we should
say in the book I talk about this sense
of attachment is seen of course in
homosexual unions it's seen in polyandry
which of course not reproductive unions
it's seen in polyandry it's seen in
polygyny it's seen in monogamous
cultures so the important thing that's
very constant the world over is not how
we pay it's seen in arranged marriages
so so even though love is seen as a
dangerous phenomenon in countries that
have arranged marriages it's dangerous
before marriage even in countries with
arranged marriages love is seen as a
very much to desired outcome of marriage
yeah so so it's seen as a desirable and
normal property to love your mate and if
you measure using some various
psychometric scales sort of this sort of
the passionate love scale is one of them
a partners you looking at arranged and
and marriages and non arranged or
so-called love matches within a few
years of marriage there's no difference
in factors evidence that the divorce
rate more than a little evidence that
the divorce rate of course it's
complicated to know why but the divorce
rate is also lower in arranged marriages
so anyway no matter what the marital
system and there are many all over the
world one of the universals is that
people love their partners which is
beautiful actually if you think about it
I mean one of my arguments is that these
qualities that are universal also are
good and and in fact that's one of the
reasons they're universal is that they
they were Fitness enhancing they made
our world better for us I recently did a
podcast with Caleb Jones who is a very
big non-monogamy advocate and that on
that incredibly interesting to hear his
point of view and the listeners will at
home I don't delve too deeply into that
but I'm thinking an awful lot about what
it is that he was talking about and he
also alluded to the the divorce rate
there increasingly right well there are
some there are some people I mean just
as a as a certain sort of a
matter I have no issues with polyamory
and and I I don't think and there's
certainly some people who find that very
appealing and I think that's totally
fine they can find each other and
they're adults and they can do in a free
society what they want but there is no
to my knowledge no successful society or
even commune that has endured long and I
discussed this in the book that's been
organized organized around polyamory
it's it's a very unstable arrangement
for a large group of people it's not
necessarily unstable for couples I know
many coming into a couple of couples
that practice polyamory among themselves
mmm-hmm but I don't I don't know of any
society that's organized that way or
even any commune that has survived more
than one or two generations organized
around polyamory interesting many have
tried you know the reasons you know
there do you know the reason it's very
interesting actually so um so if you
think about the establishment of utopian
sects or communes do they have a problem
which is that they want the group
members to have allegiance to the whole
community to the you're supposed to feel
a member of the whole community and and
this is why for example in many communes
not all and also in certain totalitarian
states the the family unit is a threat
to the loyalty that the individuals the
allegiance they feel to the state or to
the commune so they try to break down
the family kibbutz as in israel tried to
do this also by the way so to break down
the family unit also they try to break
down friendships for example in East
Germany everyone was you you couldn't
have friends you were because you they
could be you know Stasi agents everyone
was ratting on everyone else so this
type of so this type of breaking down
intimate connections or friendly
connections between people is is often
seen as and as necessary in order to
foster allegiance to the total group the
totality very Olien yes yes but here's
it is but here's the thing about
sexuality and love of partners so some
communes address the problem that humans
naturally love their partners and wish
to be in love and wish to be loved this
is very now
whole thing that most people feel and
all societies manifest this could be
seen as a threat to the to the
maintenance of kind of social cohesion
for these utopian sects or for example
we're talking about now but they have
adopted very different practices to
address that some sects haven't tried to
adopt polyamory so they say everyone can
there's no we don't want any sexual
jealousy everyone can have sex with
everyone else brave new world yes so so
but again for the reasons we owe to the
opposite extreme nobody can have sex
with anyone else it totally celibate but
both of those extremes are serving the
same purpose if you think about it both
those sects that want you to have sex
with everybody and those sects that want
you to have sex with nobody in both of
those cases they're trying to break down
a kind of intimate connection to
particular people they're trying to
anonymize or or atomize the experience
so so the paradox is that in communes
you could these very opposite practices
actually are in the service of the same
end which is to foster allegiance to the
group the shakers for example famously
prohibited sex which of course makes it
very difficult to sustain the community
produce but uh but anyway I'm sorry this
is a digression with enterprise you get
it yeah it's I mean you've touched on a
point that I want you to go to there
which is the fact that humans naturally
seek some sort of companionship and by
removing the ability to go deep with
either some people or anyone like I
don't every want everyone or anyone you
force people to look for this connection
elsewhere and that's where the state
comes in so is the reason that humans
are so like the state the state can't
take the place you see one of the things
that's also true is it in our ancestral
environment being alone was deadly so we
for reasons I discuss in the book we
explore the origins of friendship and
some theories as to why we developed the
capacity therefore by
oops all of this stuff which has to do
with coping with the dangers in the
environment so uh so so feeling we
evolved this kind of sense that being
alone could be dangerous and risky and
we crave intimate friendships that we
can all every human being that is
listening to this almost everyone knows
what I'm talking about when I say you
have an intimate friendship someone you
trust and you you talk to them and and
you have a sense that they know you as a
person and they value you as special and
unique you're irreplaceable to them each
of us is totally replaceable to
strangers but we are irreplaceable to
our friends right we are unique
individuals and that friendship is
special so so this this all this
apparatus that we have all these
emotions and sensibilities and behaviors
that sustain friendship in the modern
environment where you're interacting
with the people anonymously or where you
go to bureaucracies and you interact
with bureaucrats so now instead of
interacting with people face to face as
individual people you interact with them
as replaceable cogs in a system they're
just you know it's the person at the
Department of Motor Vehicles who's
you're interacting with and they're
doing their job and we all sense that as
awful and and the reason we sense it is
awful is because on some level we
recognize these are not our evolved
psychology is soaring warning warning
warning these aren't your real friends
you know these are these are these are
not real relationships and so we sense
that kind of an owe me and this is why
incidentally I also think that a lot of
online interactions make people so
miserable because our evolved psychology
wants real intimate face-to-face deep
sustained social relationships and
instead what we get is you know
acquaintances and and and that's
emitting I think so anyway so it's kind
of all of this stuff is is connected
actually absolutely it's interesting
that you touch on the online connections
because you know it's a trope to say
we're more connected than ever whilst
feeling more alone etc etc all that sort
of stuff Brett do you think it is
there's something specific about the
face-to-face
interaction about the fact that the I
think it's more than half of
communication cues and nonverbal and
whatsapp chat doesn't quite fulfill that
need yes I mean for example in promoting
the book or supporting the book I've
done a whole bunch of interviews and
I've noticed that quite a few of the
like you quite a few of the more
sophisticated podcasters even if there's
gonna be an audio only file they want to
do video that's in fact I asked you at
the beginning I said are you gonna we're
gonna do this video are you gonna record
the video or you just we're just Sita
well why is that it's because the
conversation is more natural more fluid
I can see are you laughing at my joke or
not you know I can see you're getting
bored by what I'm saying and I should
move on Emma you know those things all
of those things you know so you know
those are fundamental parts of how we
communicate got you so going back to the
real beginning the evolutionary I guess
prerogative for why we are social
species is it simply that a human on its
own is a human that's dead and our main
advantage as evolving humans was that we
could coordinate well as a group does
that there are many there many things
that have made us one of the most
descendant species on the earth humans I
think have the broadest or one of the
broad that humans have the broadest I
think ants also have an equally broad
but it's so I set that aside for a
moment yeah one of the broadest
Geographic ranges of a me animal species
so everyone knows that some animals live
in some places but not in other places
yeah but there's no place humans don't
live we live all over the world from the
Arctic to the equator in deserts in in
snow-covered plains we live everywhere
and the reason we do that is not because
of our our bodies we haven't adapted
physically although we have also in some
cases done adapted physically yeah it's
because of our culture it's because of
what we can teach each other it's
because of our ability to accumulate
knowledge so slowly over generations
people invent kayaks or they invent
parkas or slowly over generations people
invent technologies to find water in the
desert and and because of those in
we are able to to transmit that
knowledge from person to person and so
in order to survive we have to be part
of a community that has this type of
knowledge a teenager we do a lot of work
with a hodza oh actually we don't
anymore but we used to which is a one of
the last forager groups on the planet
they live around Lake IOC in Tanzania
only about a thousand of them left these
people hunt and gather for their food
just like every human did until in about
ten thousand years ago just doing ejecta
what uhm period of history did they
align with the Hutt's are still alive no
no what would they be representative of
in our past oh the way we lived until
about before the Agricultural Revolution
till about ten thousand years ago Wow so
the hodza the hodza hunt and gather for
their food they have no material
possessions to speak of they sleep out
under the stars and and they live in
this environment in in Tanzania around
Lake oh yeah see and and if I dropped
you there or me there we would we would
be killed in an environment we would die
in an environment that a hodza you know
seven year old could survive Laura
schism yeah yes yes and it's not because
of the differences in our bodies it's
because we have none of the knowledge
and so the knowledge is of course
transmitted socially it lives the
knowledge lives in the interstices
between people that's where the
knowledge lives and survives across time
then it comes into my brain and then it
goes into your brain and so forth so it
spreads across these connections this
knowledge and is produced by groups of
people this this knowledge and so this
is what it makes it possible for us to
survive this this this living socially I
think one of my favorite quotes from
Warren Buffett is that compounding
interest is the eighth for eighth wonder
of the world and it's occurring as we
see in front of us with knowledge right
I can put my hand that's I can put my
hand in a fire burn my hand and then
tell you and you know not to put your
hand in a fire without having to go
through it that factor accumulating over
however many generations yes leads to me
and you talking
the skype correct and in fact in fact
you could take you could take you could
take the average British you know high
school student that studied calculus
let's say and when they were 17 and if
you move them back 500 years they'd be
the smartest mathematician on the planet
I mean this you know this the the end
and we get calculus which you know Isaac
Newton and Leibniz invented actually
just as an aside we learn calculus we
are taught calculus at the speed at
which Newton invented it it was
astonishing Isaac Newton takes a year to
invent calculus I mean it's just the man
is just a little nature Wow
anyway so and now but the point is
you're born today and you inherit all
this stuff that everyone before you all
the domesticated animals other people
domesticated these animals thousands of
years ago all the domesticated plants
all the roads which were built in
England starting with the Romans yeah
calculus which was invented by Newton
500 years ago it's yours for free stuff
how to smelt iron you know all the
knowledge about iron and fishing hunting
fish hooks I talked about fish hooks in
the book like the invention of fish
hooks the wheel you go fire you go on
and on and on all of this stuff which
was just given to you when you were born
was cumulated by other humans across
time and and it's this that makes us so
powerful of species because we have if
you think about it rather pathetic
bodies I mean they're very few animals
our size
I don't think there's any animal our
size that we could pick in a one-on-one
battle I mean we probably didn't even
add oh yeah yeah a doe would kill yeah
you're probably about the same weight
and biomass is maybe like a cheetah or
something like that
well we dyed it with cheetah I mean I
can't even that is an animal that's
about the size that we could kill
penguin penguins not our size I mean
obviously tiny animals we you can kick a
penguin yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean any
tiny insects you could I mean they could
kill us too they're poisonous spiders
everything else but my point is
yeah we are pathetic bodies yeah I mean
it's not our bodies that are making us
powerful on this planet it's our culture
our brains that are making us powerful
I've got I've got one of the most
important questions to ask you right now
professor Christakis and it's would you
rather fight one horse-sized duck or 20
duck sized horses 20 duck sized horses
what's what's your strategy gonna be you
kick and kick one and move kick and move
kick it move you got it yeah and I mean
you actually you move to the place where
you fell the first opponent got unique
pile these bodies are like 300 well you
said 20 like like in 300 the movie all
right yeah yeah she just got mounds of
mounds of these Dead's duck-sized horses
everywhere well cool I think so I asked
one of the fittest men on the planet Dan
Bailey this question as well and he gave
the exact same answer so you are you're
on a level with elite athletes with
regards to yeah I spent years I spent
years training in the martial arts but
that's another story practicing duck
sized holes kick yet oh to get your
black belt they put you in a ring with
four guys and and you have to learn how
to fight against multiple opponents and
you know it's not easy it's for various
reasons anyway their basic techniques
you can use so if this situation occurs
I'm gonna call on you
so no I'm Way wait call Joe Rogan
instead oh yeah he'll kick them into
next week only yeah um so we've talked
to us we've talked about kind of our
evolutionary past
moving into where we are now did you
reflect in the book on what what the
advantages and disadvantages of modern
society are doing to our desire for
social cohesion yes and no I mean I'm
interested in I'm interested in the long
arc of our pre historical past you know
so we've evolved over hundreds of
thousands of years and it's only in the
last 10,000 years that we've even had
history at all that we
historical or political or cultural well
not cultural we've had a long time but
specific kinds of cultural forces acting
on us so I'm interested in the ways in
which our capacity for social
interaction and and living to get living
together were shaped at a time that
preceded the invention of cities or the
invention of the internet or anything
like that now these cultural products
the cities and Internet and everything
else are also shaping our evolutionary
trajectory but that's not the main
driver of the way we live socially today
for example my great-grandmother was
born in a little village in in southern
Greece and if she's not alive anymore
she was born over a hundred years ago
but if you you could if you had asked
her when she was alive what you know
which she was a ten year old girl how
many friends did she have and she would
have said I have one or two best friends
and they're four or five of us girls we
hang out together in this little village
in southern Greece you know a hundred
years ago and if you could ask my
daughter Lana who's now twenty-one but
back let's say when she was ten you know
ten years ago you asked her the same
question and she has an iPhone in her
pocket she would give you the same
answer
yeah so it's something deep and
fundamental about our nature about this
desire for one or two best friends most
people not everyone about about ninety
percent ninety two percent of people in
developed countries have one at least
one best friend or one intimate very
intimate social contact eight percent of
people in a percent of no one which is
very sad some of these people are
elderly widowers their spouse has died
everyone they know has died others of
them others of them have other sort of
disabilities that make it difficult for
them but anyway
so most people have the sense of they
have one or two best friends and they're
four or five of you know your intimate
friends that you hang out with and then
their broader circles the point is that
technology didn't change that right I
mean Chris this is a cultural constant
in fact we've done this we've looked
around the world in my laboratory we've
mapped networks in in Uganda in in in in
Tanzania and in
in India and in Honduras and in the
United States and wherever you go you
find the same thing people organize
themselves in the same way so it's not
to do with the technology does that
specifically maximize fitness do you
think or did it over the years like the
likelihood of survival yes yes I think
that the specific mathematical structure
of the social networks that we make and
we've done some other evidence on this
using a variety of tools from genomics
and also some actual anthropological
tools that the the mathematical
structure of networks that we make I
believe have been shaped by natural
selection how so and we okay well this
is a little hard to explain so it's a
bit of a tangent but let's divide it
we've got it we've got it listeners the
listeners are rubbing the hands together
they're ready to go come on okay so here
we go so there's a very fundamental
property about human social networks
which is that we have this thing called
degree a sorta tivity degree is the
number of connections that each person
has so it's how many friends you have
you have you have a degree five you've
got five friends I have degree ten I've
got ten friends someone else's degree
two they've got two friends and degree a
sorta tivity means people with similar
numbers of friends are preferentially
connected so popular people befriend
popular people and unpopular people
befriend unpopular people okay mmm-hmm
this property of degree is sorta tivity
is the opposite of a property known as
degree DISA sorta tivity which is a way
the airport network is organized so
unlike human social networks which have
degree of sorta tivity popular people
are connected to popular people or
unpopular people are connected to
unpopular people in the airport network
it's the opposite right we have a
hub-and-spoke system so the unpopular
airports with few connections aren't
connected to other small airports with
few connections they're all connected to
London and Gatwick and Chicago and
Denver yes and if you want to get from
one place to another place in an airport
network you've got to go from you know
New Haven Connecticut to Chicago and
then from Chicago you can go anywhere
yeah you can fly to any city so in two
hops you get there because the network
is organized in this degree disa sort of
way yes okay now if you think about it
in
which of those two kinds of networks if
an if an epidemic if you infected a
random person in in these two networks
the degree is sorted if in a degree
disorders network in which of those two
kinds of networks would you get a bigger
epidemic yes you should have you should
have the intuition that you'll get a
bigger epidemic in the degree disa sort
of network because in the degree disa
sorted of network the first person that
gets infected the next step they are
they are connected to the most popular
person and then that person spreads it
to everybody so so in a degree dis
assorted if network epidemics will
spread very rapidly whereas in a degree
a sorta t'v network like humans make
epidemics can be contained within one
part of the network so one unpopular
person gets an infection and they infect
their unpopular friends and they are all
infected over there yeah the rest of us
are okay yeah because they're not
connected to the popular person let's
say the story is more complicated than
this but this is the gist so what's very
interesting to me is that of all the
kinds of ways that we could form social
networks we form them to have this
property of resistance to epidemics
because we form a degree assorted of
networks and amazingly elephants do the
same thing this is discussed in the book
and sewed whale so do orcas and so other
social mammals when they go about making
their friendship networks even though
our last common ancestor with those with
elephants was 85 million years ago they
independently have converged on the same
way of social socially organizing
themselves that gives them this sort of
epidemic resistance property at the
population level that's so fascinating
so yeah so these are some ideas about
you know in response to what you asked
that's really fascinating and it makes
complete sense I totally understand I
think um one of the things that's come
to mind
Dunbar's number which is yeah supposed
up early
it's upper bound that a human can have
in terms of friends did you look at that
and I've never delved into this is there
is that like a gospel or is there some
some criticism of that yeah so Robin
Dunbar is a very famous physical
anthropologist at madlyn college at
Oxford he he is well known for this
finding which is a correct finding which
is that human beings it's not the upper
limit it's that on average our capacity
to track social relationships that is at
about 150 and he made this prediction
based on a comparative analysis of
different primate species and the size
of their groups and there's been
abundant evidence sort of confirming his
ideas in this regard and the notion is
that is that you are able to our brains
are endowed with the ability to and he
uses as a kind of approximation of what
he means by knowing someone is knowing
someone is if you can pick up your
conversation where you left off where
you left it off before uh-huh so you
remember enough of who they are and what
kinds of things you're discussing so
that if you meet them again after an
absence you can pick up the conversation
and so he the number of people we can do
this with is about 150 we can we we can
know if these people are friends or
enemies we can also know something about
the relationships of all the pairs of
people so you know if you have a hundred
friends you know does this person like
that person or not get along and for
example many of the listeners will have
this experience some listeners will have
gone to high schools that had small but
I know the word is different in England
in British English and American English
so when I say class I mean the group of
people that are in you know your yeah
your year exactly so there might be in
in your school let's say it's a it's a
it's a it's a private school and there
are a small year of let's say a hundred
students yeah if you went to such a
school you know that you know every
other student and you knew something
about the relationships of every other
student and if you contrast that for
example with a with a municipal school
that's run by the state which is bigger
and there might be a thousand people in
your year or 500 people in your year you
know you didn't know all those thousand
people
and you didn't know the relationships of
all those people and that's the
limitation of your of your brain of our
brains so so this is what Robin Dunbar's
uh arguments are about do you think that
that was maximizing evolutionary fitness
as well I do remember when I spoke to I
think in our ancestral environment we
didn't need two brains that could track
larger numbers of people because there
weren't bigger groups I see apparently I
was again William von Hippel is the
closest podcast I've done to what we're
discussing at the moment I think he
alluded to the fact or at least posited
that groups over he said around about 50
he thought would tend to disband he
thought that groups at least when we're
talking Australopithecus that kind of
era that those groups would disband into
groups of 50 because the larger groups
end up being I think it was I can't
remember the reason why but he I think
he thought that was the case yes and he
may be right I don't know the answer
that question there's a there's a lot of
suggestive evidence about the group
sizes of ancestral hominids we can
certainly study living primates and do
comparisons and that's what what Robin
Dunbar did for his analysis mm-hmm I got
you so moving forwards as we as we go on
obviously you have looked at the pasta
you have any predictions about the
future do you have any sort of
suggestions for the future well I mean
one kind of speculative set of ideas
that interest me right now is what I
call hybrid systems of humans and
machines so increasingly you know the
relationship between human beings and
technology is an ancient topic you know
Homer talks about this in the Iliad you
know what's the role of bronze spears in
warfare you know we invent a new a new
technology and it has you know certain
implications for example or or you know
dizziest uses the Trojan horse to get it
to the city you know that's a technology
and and you know you have the Luddites
you know breaking the the looms you know
in England and so there's lots of you
know our relationship technology is
complicated and long-standing
but what's different now is that we are
beginning to endow these machines with a
kind of volition of their own I mean
they're not obviously human they don't
really have their own desires but
they're able to act independently and
they're living amongst us so we have
digital assistants like Alexa for
example or we have autonomous vehicles
on the car
on the road so you're driving down the
road and they're mostly human drivers
but they're also some autonomous
vehicles that are driving down the road
doing their thing or online you know we
you have your Twitter friends and you
know I'm on Twitter and some of the
people that follow me I think are bots
you know and so there they are they're
in the system they're humans and some
bots that are interacting I call this a
hybrid system because it's hybrid
between humans and machines but what's
interesting to me is not the
interactions between a human and a
machine it's the ways in which the
presence of those machines acting as if
they were human modifies how we interact
with each other let me give you an
example
so you add bring an Alexa into your home
and the people who design the Alexa make
it want to make it very obedient they're
not interested in you having to do you
could just say you know you know play
Little Richard you know or play
Beethoven and the Machine does what you
ask or you know order milk he doesn't
you don't have to say please could you
order some milk or would you please you
know do this whatever you don't have to
be polite to the Machine yeah but think
about how the addition of this machine
into a home might train a child to be
rude and it's not a problem if the child
is rude to the Alexa but then the child
goes to the school yard and is rude to
his or her friends and so now we have a
rude group of children that has arisen
because of the introduction of this
machine into the social system or you
think about driverless cars in a world
in which we have only human drivers
they're all human and eventually we'll
have a world in which they're only
autonomous vehicles none of us will
drive cars anymore you'll go to
racetracks to drive cars that it's like
thirty years from now if not sooner so
uh and those cars will be will be
Bluetooth enabled and they will
communicate with each other and they'll
move in a kind of laminar flow down the
highway or they'll entrain with each
other and they'll be fine there'll be no
collisions it'll be all fine but between
now and then we're gonna have a hybrid
system of humans and machines and the
question is how should we program those
autonomous vehicles so that as they move
among us they improve rather than
degrade our behavior so for example the
car maker might want to design the car
to move very smoothly so that the
occupant of the autonomous vehicle has a
nice Pleasant ride but now the human
drivers behind this vehicle might be
lulled into a false sense of security
and become inattentive and so when they
veer off to go and go to the part of the
highway that has just human vehicles
these inattentive drivers might cause
more collisions now the person who
bought the vehicle the autonomous
vehicle and the designer of the
autonomous vehicle doesn't care at all
about those people who are you know
killing themselves over there because of
the new bad driving practices but we
should care so so one of the things I'm
concerned about is the ways in which
these new technologies in the future are
going to reshape our social interactions
are going to modify how we live together
and might potentially threaten some of
these fundamentally good qualities about
how we have evolved to live together
that you and I've been talking about
moving on where can the listeners find
you online if they want to find out a
little bit more uh well my laboratory is
WW human nature lab dotnet and of course
we've been talking about my book
blueprint the evolutionary origin of a
good society which is available
everywhere and on my lab we have videos
and paper scientific papers and all
kinds of other information people want
to delve deep it will be in the show
notes below along with the links to
blueprint and your Twitter yes I'm on
Twitter of course you are incredibly
interesting on Twitter I'm looking
forward to reading through some of your
stuff oh good save for this evening
professor Christakis I'm really
appreciate your time thank you so much
for coming on thank you for having very
much Chris I'm very grateful
[Music]